and thomas here with me now so some
investigations
inquiries is there any likelihood of a
clear
conclusion to this a decision anytime
soon
well there's never a conclusion in one
sense to anything in politics because
voters always have to make up their mind
i referred to the fact in that report
that you know
voters will go to the polls next week
and we might get a sense of
what they think about this then it's
important to say there doesn't seem to
be much sign of it cutting through
tonight there's a poll from
yougov which still puts the conservative
party 11 points
ahead that is days and days of this kind
of coverage
uh not apparently making much difference
at the ballot box and
throughout the conservative party
they're incredibly uh relieved about
that but we will
the electoral commission investigation
is likely to take some months but we
will get the first indication
of the seriousness of boris johnson
personally in terms of consequences
just after the local elections uh we've
learned tonight that
um the labour party labour mps have
asked some
of our the parliamentary commissioners
to standards to look at whether or not
boris johnson break rules uh personally
now under some recently revisited rules
the parliamentary commissioner for
standards will say whether or not
they're investigating but tonight put
out a statement
saying that they will make that clear in
the week after the local elections
so maybe 10th or 11th or the few days
after that
we will find out whether prima facie the
allegations that have been
made are serious enough for boris
johnson to face
an investigation by that parliamentary
commissioner
for status on top of the existing uh
investigation that she's conducting into
that holiday in january 2020 december
uh 19 uh in mustique uh which um
for which there are questions about
quite how it has been uh
as well uh questions about who exactly
paid for uh part of that holiday
so um there is a worry inside bits the
conservative party that there are
so many different investigations uh that
one of them
could just come up with an extremely
politically inconvenient uh conclusion
but
at the moment voters don't seem to be
listening